يعمل منذ سنوات كسائق شاحنه لجمع النفايات
كان ينتظر بفارغ الصبر تقاعده لكن القانون
الجديد احبط عزيمته بعدما زاد من انتظاره
عامين على الاقل
انهم يحقون في اضربهم فالعمل حتى السن
الرابعه والستين مع هذا العمل الشاق امر
مستحيل خلال المطر والبرد ولدينا مشاكل
بالظهر والركبتين في هذا السن نكون قد
متنا اصلا هذا مهلك ما تفعله الحكومه
وامام معمل حرق النفايات لم يتوانى
متظاهرون من النقابات عن نصب خيامهم من
اجل دعم عمال النظافه المضربين هنا ضد
قانون رفع سن التقاعد
القانون لم يخضع اصلا للتصويت الحكومه
استخدمت البنت
49.3 من اجل تمرير القانون دون تصويت
البرلمان عليه وهذا يتعارض مع الديمقراطيه
عبر اكوام متراكمه من النفايات يحاول عمال
النظافه ايصال صوتهم الى الحكومه قد يكون
ذلك وسيلتهم الوحيده للتعبير عن غضبهم لكن
هذا المشهد المتكرر في احياء باريس بدا
يؤثر على صورتها السياحيه ويؤرق زوارها
ونزعج بالمانيا
يعني انصدمت انه مليان زباله
يعني مو مثل واحد متوقع المفروض حتى لو في
ضربات في مشاكل نظافه يعني عمال نظافه
بالذات ما في
اضراب حتى والله حاولنا نقدم لحد بس
للاسف ورغم جهود الحكومه في توفير شركات
خاصه لازاله النفايات من شوارع العاصمه
لكن الازمه لم تنتهي بعد وما زال فيها
اكثر من 9000 طن من القمامه وهو ما قد
يستغرق اياما عديده لجمعها
بعيدا عن اكوام النفايات المتراكمه هنا
وهناك في شارع شانزليزي يحاول السياح
التقاط صور تذكاريه لا تشوهها الازمه
الناجمه عن قانون رفع سن التقاعد والتي
غطت على سحر اشهر مدينه سياحيه في العالم
وحولتها الى مجمع النفايات وساحه معركه
مشتعله بين الحكومه وفئات من شعبها زين
عدي العربيه باريس